we're so vulnerable cuz we're all like
like women are so like a hot woman like
a really hot woman is so [__]
powerful take it easy anyone else hard J
why' you just say it like when you see
Lauren Sanchez and Jeff Bezos you're
like I get it yeah and they know who
who's a trick from Transformers Megan
Fox oh yeah just like you can do
whatever you want with anybody yes stop
was talking about her the other day I
only got the F for once which is you
know you didn't do a great job but I did
eat her [__] for I got that was my
first encounter with a squirter we
congratulations thanks man that's
amazing thanks man I are you sure it's
real I mean you're you sure she wasn't
peeing all over you she it was clear I
thought about say how often do you pee
and it's not clear and it's not clear
yeah quite a bit I'm not very hydrated
okay that's not
good it's so easy